[Music]
hey you guys book review time
this time i have sort of a
recommendation
um also something that had to do with a
movie that we reviewed kind of recently
i don't think this one was on my tbr
because i think that i just kind of
picked this one up
on a whim because somebody mentioned it
to me so this is actually
a sort of a short story collection
and it's called wounds by nathan
balangrid hopefully i'm pronouncing that
right balingrad
i'm sure i'm in the ballpark sorry
nathan so how i came to review this book
was that
a while back i talked about i think it
was maybe on one of our matinee shows we
talked about this movie
called wounds that came out in 2019
and i thought that it was based on a
book and then somebody in the comments i
can't remember who but they said
yeah there's like a book and it's called
wounds and one of the stories in there
is the basis for that movie
so i kind of got really interested and
then i had kind of heard the name
uh nathan ballenger before because i
think in the horror community he kind of
made a bit of a splash with his
uh previous short story collection which
was called north american lake monsters
and i think they were even talking about
making that one into
a series if i'm remembering correctly i
haven't read that one yet but i
actually after reading this one i will
probably go back and read that one
although from what i hear both of these
are kind of very different
so i kind of feel like north american
lake monsters from
what reviews and stuff i read about it
was more
concerned with you know people in
realistic situations
who have this one you know monster or
fantastical element that kind of
intrudes upon them
and and then the stories are kind of
concerned with
what this incursion of the supernatural
i guess or the monstrous
does to them as human beings now wounds
is a lot different i will say if you are
into
early clive barker like books of blood
clive barker you will probably really
really dig this
i'm not saying that it's a clyde barker
ripoff or anything like that but it's
kind of in the same
ballpark at least this one this
particular um
short story collection is so what we
have here it's six stories
now some of them like two or three of
them are pretty short
and then there are a couple in there
that are kind of long that are like
novella length
and they all are thematically linked
the subtitle of the book is six stories
from the border of hell
so basically the theme of it is all
about
people that are trying to get to hell
people that are trying to summon hell
somehow
but the weird thing about it it's not
it's sort of like the classical hell
that you're thinking of
with satan and demons and everything but
there's also something of a really kind
of you know dante or milton-esque kind
of thing going on
another thematic thing too is almost
kind of like i think
what he's getting at in this collection
is that the worst hell
is i don't want to say is is love
but is maybe unrequited love i kind of
get because there's a lot of uh
you know thematic elements like love
story elements in these
and i don't want to say it's not like a
rom-com or anything like that this is
like i said this is like early clive
barker it has a lot of dark fantasy
elements there's a lot of world building
it's really really gory so if you
i mean there's like beings that climb
inside of humans
like and their skin doesn't fit and they
wear them like clothing there's like all
this kind of crazy
uh [ __ ] going on it's like cannibalism
dismemberment
just blood gore it's very very very gory
so if you if you don't like that kind of
thing that you're not gonna like this
because it's very very gory but yeah so
what we have here is six stories that
they're kind of they have different
settings they have different characters
but there are some themes that are
repeated and some kind of
objects and stuff like that that kind of
turn up in each of them so it's almost
it's interesting because even though the
stories are sort of wildly different
they all share a kind of vibe and they
all
share a universe so i guess he's kind of
like just creating this extended
universe and he's just telling all of
these different stories
within it which i thought was really
cool so i guess the first
five stories in this were previously
published in
various other places the sixth one which
is called the butchers table
is actually was written particularly for
this book so that's so it's a new thing
so let me kind of go into well let me
mention first
that the story that the movie wounds was
based on
is actually the fifth story in here and
it's called the visible filth
i think this was released maybe as a
chat book like on its own because it's i
think it's about 100 pages long or
something like it's like like i said
like novella length
and that story i guess a lot of people
didn't like the movie i actually liked
the movie um the story is much better
you know having seen the movie first and
then read the story
it seems like they did as well as they
could like translating
the story into movie form so i thought
the movie was like a pretty good
adaptation
obviously like i said the story is
better now the story of the visible
filth
is easily the most grounded in reality
so if you've read if you read north
american lake monsters and you liked
that more realistic take
rather than a more dark fantasy take
then the visible filth is pretty much
the only one that still has
that grounded in reality sort of thing
the other ones are much
more were in the hell razor dimension
kind of thing so it's
you know like i said this is dark
fantasy it's
kind of shades into weird fiction too
there are some realistic elements but
not so many
however the visible filth is pretty much
grounded in the real world in the modern
world and it just has to do
with a guy named will who is a bartender
in new orleans and there's a fight at
his bar one night
and this girl like in the scuffle she
drops her cell phone and she forgets it
there
and so he takes it he like puts it in
his pocket he's gonna you know get back
to her later on
and then he's kind of looking through
there to see whose it is
and he finds these really horrific
pictures
and videos it's like it's hard i don't
want to give too much away because
you know there's a movie based on it and
like i said i don't want it but it's
almost kind of like referring to this
it's sort of like a cult i guess or some
kind of like interdimensional
beings or something and they come
through to our world through people's
wounds both physical wounds and
emotional wounds
so that's kind of what you have going on
in that story like
i said it has some fantastical elements
to it um you know like kind of
interdimensional or like something
coming from hell or whatever
but it's very very much based in reality
that story
the other five not so much so like i
said that's the fifth story and that's
the one that the movie was based on
so the first story in this is called the
atlas of hell
and this is basically it's almost kind
of like a noir
like a gangster type of story but with
hell elements involved so basically you
have this guy his name is jack oleander
and he's like a rare book dealer and he
gets summoned to find like for this
gangster
something called the atlas of hell now
he's assuming as you would
uh that it's a book but that does not
turn out to be the case
so he actually ends up at the in the
middle of this [ __ ] swamp in new
orleans somewhere at this tiny little
shack where this person that has the
atlas of hell
uh lives and you find out like i said i
don't know if i want to spoil too much
of these it's like they're so weird
that i don't know i always went well i
okay i will say
that it's not a book what the atlas of
hell is
and you don't really find out like it's
an
object inside another object let's say
that and it can do [ __ ] like
if you open let's okay so it's in an
iron box and if you open the iron box
that it's in
then it sort of like pollutes the
environment around it like it almost
kind of like warps
uh you know the surrounding area and
people into other things like it's
turning them
into you know demons not i don't know i
don't want to say that because that
sounds a little pedestrian
but it turns things and it turns people
into something
else like it transforms them but you the
interesting thing is you don't
find out what the deal is with the atlas
of hell why
this particular object is the atlas
until the last story the butcher's table
which actually comes back like full
circle again
and explains where that atlas came from
and why it ended up at that place so i
thought that was kind of cool
that all of the stories while very very
different
are sort of interconnected like they're
all kind of in the same universe
you know what i'm saying but yeah so i
thought that was kind of a cool idea so
that's the first story
like i said very gangster very noir it
reminded me a little bit and i know i'm
gonna say like oh a lot of them reminded
me of clyde barker but they did um this
one actually kind of reminded me a
little bit of his
of clive barker's novel the damnation
game a little bit i haven't read that in
a long time but it gave me that same
sort of
vibe i guess uh but yeah so like i said
if you like early clive barker you'll
probably super super dig this so the
second story which
i think was the shortest also i think
maybe the weakest um it's still a good
story but i thought
out of all the six i think this is the
one that i liked the least this is
called um the diabolist
and it's basically about a girl whose
dad was a diabolist and he was
summoning you know demons from various
hell dimensions or whatever
uh in his basement and he dies
and she is trying to
bring him back to life because i guess
he had summoned
this one thing they don't really tell
you
what it is uh it comes from the love
mills
in hell like i said there's a lot of
love elements in this of
of hell being i guess unrequited love or
longing you know something like that so
i guess that the dad was trying to
summon like bring his wife back from the
dead
and it didn't work out and then this
other
thing came and so this story is written
from the thing's perspective
and it's almost like the thing is
talking to you
the reader but also kind of talking to
the girl in the story that's trying to
like take up her dad's
work or whatever so yeah that was a
little weird like i said it's kind of
shorter i think that was probably like
my least favorite of the collection like
i said it's still a good story but it
was probably like my least favorite
now i will say too that other than the
visible filth which like i said is kind
of more like a realistic story you know
with just fantastical elements
sort of threaded through it these are
very plot-centric
world-building you know fantasy type
stories so
there are good characters in them but
if you're really into getting like super
deep into
uh you know a character's mind or
something like that
these stories aren't really so much like
that like i said the characters are kind
of
just sketchily drawn kind of so it's
more about
i don't know it's more about the world
and it's more about
that kind of stuff you know what i mean
so it's more like a bigger picture
i guess type of thing rather than like
character studies and i guess that's
kind of uh a general thing with short
stories anyway because you don't have as
much time to
you know get inside the heads of these
characters or spend a lot of time with
these characters because the stories are
so short
but i'm just saying that if you're
really into like character based horror
this is not so much that like i said
other than visible filth which actually
does have the main character of will
and his girlfriend and you know this
other girl that he knows like his best
friend
um that has a lot more kind of character
depth in it but the other ones are kind
of more
fantasy based so they're more kind of
about they're more about the world
building
you know what i mean and like how
horrific this this [ __ ] is
and the writing style i will say is like
really really
man he's really good at describing [ __ ]
like some of the stuff because
i mean some of the stuff that's in the
stories is crazy
you know what i mean just like crazy you
know there's like one of the stories
called the maw
there's all these beings that have taken
over this particular neighborhood and
everybody is
gone like all and all the buildings are
hollowed out
and so they basically just take people
in wheelbarrows
you know just dead people or live ones
or whatever and they
kind of dismember them and skin them and
they kind of put all their skin
like like bunting like all around the
place for some reason known only to them
because like i said they're from hell
dimension so yeah third story i think
because i mentioned yeah the diabolist
like i said very it's very brief and
it's kind of like just
it's almost more like a sketch or a
vignette than a story i guess
um but yeah that was probably my least
favorite but it's still a good story so
the third one
is kind of interesting the third one is
called skull pocket
now this one is almost like a weird
like dark comedy like why a type of
thing because
this has to do with a town
called hobbs landing which for a second
i was just kind of like
is that like in the mouth of madness but
no that's hobbs end but close enough
so this is basically about there's so
there's a society of
ghouls who are like
they're not like zombies they're like
people but they just kind of
they eat people they're like little
cannibals or whatever
and they have a whole society like going
on underground that
that normal that the normal world
doesn't know about so
this story is like there's there's a
town called hobbs end
and the ghouls have taken this town over
so they've summoned 14
children to this thing that they call
the skull pocket fair
which they have i guess they have every
year or however long and they always
have 14 kids come so you have the kind
of host of the skull pocket fair
kind of clueing these kids in about the
history
of hobbs end and how the ghouls came to
take over the town they they even have
their own religion
like the order of the maggot and it's
sort of about so like i said it's a very
very clyde bark
club barkery and you know what i mean
it's just it just kept
like ringing all the clive parker bells
but you know what i mean so it's kind of
like that so it
so it's kind of like whimsical but like
in a real
[ __ ] up sort of way you know i mean
it's like you know little kids like
pulling other little kids
like little little kid ghouls like
pulling normal
kids heads off and using their skulls
for you know for the game which is
called skull pocket but skull pocket has
another meaning as well
so yeah so there's that whole thing so
like i said as you can see
these are ha these are like wildly
different
kind of stories you know what i'm saying
it's so they have like all different
kind of vibes but they're kind of
linked in a weird way as well so the
fourth story which i think i already
mentioned
uh is called the maw also pretty brief
it's just basically about this
neighborhood
or this town that's called the hollow
city and for whatever reason
all of these demons or you know hell
beings or whatever have come and taken
over this place
everybody has left and they all live it
so inside the town it's just all kind of
like all the buildings are hollowed out
like i said they kind of string skin and
arms and legs and [ __ ] all over the
place just because that's what they do
and there's a guy named carlos
who used to live in this area but you
know evacuated
and he wants to go back in there to find
his dog
maria because he's he thinks that maria
has run back to their old house
and so i guess there's been like um
since whatever happened happened
there has been kind of a trade in all
these kind of
uh teenage kids that you can hire to be
a guide to go
into this hellscape town so you don't
get hurt
like and uh so he hires this girl named
mix
to go and look for the dog for him and
the reason it's called the moth is
because they go in one of the buildings
and you know there's like a big hell
mouth in there or whatever
so that one was pretty good too i kind
of feel like i don't know
the intriguing thing about these stories
is that a lot of them
particularly the short ones it just
seems like there's so much more going
on like outside the boundaries of the
story if that makes any sense you know
what i mean because some of the ones are
so brief and they just
kind of give you just these briefest
glimpses of oh this and that is going on
over there
and they don't really there's not really
any reason for you don't really know the
reason for it so it's like a really
interesting intriguing
i i kind of like that it's sort of more
subtle like he didn't he didn't go super
into this is the way this works and
that's the way that works like some of
the stories have those aspects to it
but a lot of it is kind of left to your
imagination or you know why that could
be or whatever
because i do kind of feel like maybe the
stories were just like well that's just
how it is we're just not questioning it
you know what i mean so there is kind of
that
sort of thing to it so as i said if
you're real into kind of
like i said more traditional horror or
more narrative horror or something like
that
probably this won't be your cup of tea
but if you're into
clyde barker if you're in a weird
fiction you should probably like really
dig this
um and like i said it's super gory so
you know just
take that under advisement uh so yeah so
the fifth story is the visible filth
which i already talked about
easily my favorite one of the collection
and then the last one is the butcher's
table now this one
takes place i'm not sure why this takes
place during
um the days when uh
pirates you know pirates of caribbean
days
you know whatever that was but you know
what i mean so you have like pirate
ships
uh and uh they were raiden uh whatnot
and
so basically the story in this one is
that there's a guy
who's in like a secret society
and he's going to the
borderlands of hell pretty much they're
going to the shores of hell
and he hires this guide and then he
hires a boat
like a ship that's going to take him
there another thing they're going to so
there's several things going on at once
because this one's kind of like
you really have to read this one and
follow it because there's like a bunch
of different stories and it kind of
jumps around
so he's going to
marry his fiancee who is from a secret
society but like an even more like
demonic whatever like that's like
actually closer to hell than
than his so he's gonna marry her and he
wants to marry her on the shores of hell
um because it's just kind of like this
like i said it's very it's very very
um it's very dante it's very milton it's
that kind of stuff like you know what i
mean like the the shore
i really loved this image but like the
shore of hell when like when they pull
the ship
up to it a bunch of the landscape is
made
out of a humongous dead angel
you know what i mean like there's like a
cave but it's made out of like the
angels like crushed skull and it's like
this just this massive
being and it makes up like a whole bunch
so it's this this kind of stuff
so there's that going on he's trying to
get there and they're also trying to do
this feast because there's like the
the woman that he's gonna marry is she's
in this
i guess you'd call them satanists sorta
and they do call them that in the story
a little bit sometime but they're also
cannibals so they have a thing where
the most holy thing you can do is to
kind of give your body to be
you know to be literally eaten by the
other satanists you know what i'm saying
so they're doing all of this at once so
it's kind of cool because these
pirate ships and then they have this
thing on there that's kind of like
half plant half human and they need to
have that because
the sound that it makes when you hurt it
gives you access to
what they call like the dark water
because you have to like goes like sail
over the
ocean and then uh you know at some point
this plant human hybrid thing has to
make a noise
and it sort of opens the gates of the to
the dark water but then once you get
into the dark water
there's other ships there called the
black law which
they're trying to keep people off the
hell shores because they don't want
people just like wandering in there
so like this is a very complicated and
it's not it's longer than the other
stories but it's not super super long i
think it's about 100 pages
but there's a lot going on in this and
like i said there's a whole bunch of
characters with a lot of
um you know what a lot of their motives
are like are at cross purposes so
there's like a lot of
you know backstabbing and double dealing
and all that kind of stuff so you really
kind of have to pay attention to this
one
this was the newest one and like i said
the newest story in the collection and
this was the only one that had not been
previously published published because
this was written for uh specifically for
this book
interestingly when you get to one point
of this story
you discover where the atlas of hell
from the first story came from
um and like i said i don't know should i
say what it is
i don't know i shouldn't say what it is
but uh but yeah so you kind of feel like
i said it's not it's not a book it's not
a map
it's not anything like that you know
what i mean so uh but you find out where
this so i really really liked
because for a while i was kind of this
one i had a little bit of a trouble
following it just because there's so
many characters and i was just like okay
we'll
wait who's this now and like what ship
are we on and uh you know stuff and i
was trying to
keep track of everyone's agendas so this
one is like you really have to pay
attention but when that detail came up i
was like oh
and then i was just kind of like oh and
it's co so it all kind of like
because i think previous to this there
had been some references to some things
in other stories you know what i mean
because you know the story
skull pocket where they're talking about
the town of hobs end and they talk about
the history and how the ghouls took over
and integrated with the
humans and all this other kind of stuff
but then if you look back
at the story the diabolist which is the
one before that
the dad that died was also from that
town
so like i said it's like an extended
universe type of thing going on which i
thought was a really really cool
idea and it's not really something you
see a lot in short story collections i
guess it's like some people do it i
guess but it's almost kind of like a
love crafty and
you know what i mean like so you know
how lovecraft had the necronomicon and
had some other things and then
other authors took it up and [ __ ] like
that as well but so this kind of seems
like that it just seems like six
stories that take place in this same
universe but with overlapping elements
but
they're each their own stories you know
what i'm saying so like i said five of
them
seem to take place in the present day
although some of them are so
fantastical that it doesn't really
matter you know if that makes any sense
the visible filth is is very grounded in
the real world but that's the only one
that is
um i'm not sure if that's why that one
was my favorite
or i don't know because i was the most
familiar with that one i guess because
i'd already
seen the movie i don't know i just i
really like i liked all the other ones
too i think this is like a really really
good book
i'm just saying it's not for everybody
um if you're into clyde barker if you're
into weird fiction
if you really like this kind of like
interesting
take on hell which is sort of like
literal hell like it's really there you
it's a place and you can go to it
but it's not exactly like you know it's
it's not
exactly like hell in the traditional
sense and i think he did a lot of really
interesting things with that concept
so if that sounds like something that
you would be into
then probably you should check this one
out because you'll probably really
really dig it
and like i said his uh his writing style
is really really is really good because
all of these fantastical things that are
happening and he's describing it so well
that you can just like see it you know
what i mean
it's very very cinematic like you can
see exactly what it looks like
and i thought that was like really cool
as i said i'm usually more
into i love clyde barker i'm not saying
that but um i'm usually more into
you know grounded and reality type
stories or you know ghost stories or
psychological horror things like that so
this is this is a genre that i read a
little bit less of
but saying that i really really like
this a lot i
enjoyed it very much some of the stories
were a little bit
weak for me but overall i thought this
was like really really good
so i would recommend it if that sounds
like your cup of tea
and uh that'll do it for this tomes of
terror
and i will see you on the next one bye